Um, imagine laughing so hard at a joke that you just, you instantly lose all muscle control
and collapse to the floor.
Just completely drop, yeah.
Right. Or, uh, perhaps you end up kicking your spouse in your sleep, only to find out from
a doctor that this, like, seemingly harmless quirk is actually a blaring warning sign for
a neurological disease.
A disease you won't fully develop for another, what, 10 years?
Exactly. 10 whole years.
Welcome to today's Deep Dive, everyone. We are so glad you are joining us today
because we're looking at sleep. And sleep is not just a simple off switch, you know?
It's a chaotic, highly active, factory floor operating in the dark.
It really is. And, you know, things can break down in incredibly specific, sometimes bizarre ways.
Yeah. So today we are pulling from the past ready prep clinical notes. We're doing a deep
dive into sleep-wake disorders.
And I think what makes this fascinating for you listening is how these notes frame it.
We often treat sleep like an isolated medical event, right?
But today we're looking at it through the specific lens of a mental health counselor.
Which changes everything. Because if you were sitting in that counselor's chair,
you need a playbook.
You really do.
Patients are going to walk into your office completely exhausted. You have to, like,
act as a detective. Our mission today is to decode the clues they give you.
Right. Pass out the behavioral hurdles that you can actively fix in the therapy room
versus the physiological hardware failures that require an immediate medical referral.
Exactly. The software versus the hardware. So let's start with the software.
The absolute baseline of sleep dysfunction, which is insomnia disorder.
Yeah. Clinically coded as F51.01. It's important to note this isn't just, you know,
having a restless night because you drank too much coffee.
Or you're stressed about a presentation.
Right. Exactly. The diagnostic threshold here is very rigid. A patient has to experience
trouble falling asleep, staying asleep, or waking up far too early at least three nights a week.
Wow. Three nights a week.
Yeah. And for a minimum of three months.
Three solid months. I mean, that is a massive chunk of your life spent just staring at the
ceiling agonizing. And the notes specify that it must cause significant daytime impairment.
So mood disturbances, cognitive fog, or just a total inability to function at work.
Yeah. The duration and the impairment are what elevated to an actual clinical disorder.
But the thing that really stood out to me for a counselor is how we traditionally treat
this in our culture. Oh, the chemical sledgehammer.
Exactly. The cultural reflex for not being able to sleep is to just reach for a pill.
But the pass-ready prep notes take a super definitive stance against this for chronic
insomnia. They absolutely do. Because, well, what those pills actually do to our sleep
architecture is essentially create counterfeit rest.
Counterfeit rest. I like that. It's like if you treat chronic insomnia with a hypnotic medication,
you are inducing a state of sedation, right? Not restorative sleep.
Right. You're just sedated. The medication often forcefully suppresses REM sleep and deep,
slow-wave sleep. So you are unconscious, but the brain isn't doing the necessary
defragmentation and cellular repair. You wake up technically having been asleep,
but you're biologically completely unrefreshed. It's like forcing your computer to power down
by yanking the cord out of the wall without actually running the maintenance cycle.
Yeah. And the underlying behavioral corrupted files, like the anxiety about getting into bed,
the racing thoughts, they are all still sitting there on the hard drive waiting for you when
that pill wears off. Which is why if a treatment plan leads with medication for chronic insomnia,
that is a glaring red flag. So what is the alternative?
The source material emphasizes a high value answer for counselors, right?
Yes. The first line standard of care is cognitive behavioral therapy for insomnia or CBTI.
CBTI. Got it. And that's not just like drinking chamomile tea and taking a warm bath.
No, no. It is a highly structured intervention. It involves rigorous behavioral rewiring. For
instance, they use sleep restriction therapy, which sounds totally counterintuitive.
Wait. Sleep restriction for someone who can't sleep?
Yeah. If someone is only sleeping four hours a night, but they're spending nine hours in bed
tossing and turning, CBTI compresses their allowed time in bed to just four or five hours.
Oh, wow. So you just severely limit the bedtime.
Right. Which builds up this overwhelming biological sleep drive. You are so exhausted
by the time you're finally allowed into bed that you just crash immediately.
You essentially force the body to crave sleep again.
Exactly. And then you slowly expand the sleep window. You combine that with stimulus control.
So training the brain that the bed is exclusively for sleep.
You break the association between the mattress and the anxiety.
You're actively rewriting the software of the patient's sleep habits.
Okay. So that's the software bug. You treat that with behavioral therapy.
But what happens when a patient walks into the office equally exhausted,
but the issue isn't their software at all?
The hardware glitches.
Right. Let's look at a patient whose brain is just fundamentally misfiring its sleep-wake
regulation during the day.
Okay. So this moves us into narcolepsy territory. Clinical code G47.4. Narcolepsy is characterized
by recurrent, irrepressible attacks of sleep during waking hours.
But how does a counselor differentiate this from just the sheer exhaustion of severe insomnia?
They're listening for a very specific physiological tell.
Cataplexy.
Yes. Cataplexy.
This blew my mind. The sudden loss of bilateral muscle tone while the person is fully awake.
Typically triggered by a strong emotion.
Like laughter, surprise, anger.
You're just hanging out with a friend. They tell a good joke.
You laugh and your knees just buckle.
The mechanism behind it is fascinating.
So during normal REM sleep, your brain actively paralyzes your major voluntary muscles, right?
So you don't act out your dreams.
Right. A safety lock.
Exactly.
But in narcolepsy, the boundary between sleep and wakefulness is severely degraded.
When a strong emotion activates the amygdala, it essentially short-circuits the hypothalamus.
And it causes that REM sleep paralysis to just intrude directly into waking life.
Yes. The brain confuses the emotional spike with the cue to initiate sleep paralysis.
And because this is a profound hardware glitch,
specifically involving a lack of the neurotransmitter hypocretin, right?
Right. Hypocretin.
A counselor cannot fix this with talk therapy.
No. Your lane as a counselor shifts entirely to recognition and referral.
Narcolepsy requires medical management.
A neurologist or sleep specialist will intervene with scheduled naps and medications.
And the source notes point to modafinil, correct?
They do. Modafinil is interesting because it's not a traditional amphetamine-style stimulant.
It doesn't just flood the system and make you all jittery.
Right. It acts as a wakefulness-promoting agent.
It targets specific histamine and dopamine pathways to keep you alert
without the massive cardiovascular spikes.
Okay. So narcolepsy is a failure to stay awake.
But what about when a patient comes in exhausted, not because of a daytime misfire,
but because they are unknowingly fighting for their life every single night?
Obstructive sleep apnea hypopnea.
Yes. Code G47.33.
Sleep apnea is incredibly prevalent and just physically devastating.
The hallmark symptoms are repeated pauses in breathing during sleep,
accompanied by loud, earth-shattering snoring.
Because the airway physically collapses, cutting off oxygen.
The physiological panic that induces is wild.
The brain senses the oxygen dropping, sounds the alarm, and spikes the sympathetic nervous system.
It floods the body with cortisol and adrenaline
to force you awake just enough to gasp for air.
And this microarousal happens dozens, sometimes hundreds of times a night.
The patient's sleep architecture is entirely fragmented.
They never reach those restorative, deep sleep stages
because their body is constantly interrupting the cycle to prevent suffocation.
They wake up feeling like they've been hit by a truck.
And again, you do not treat a collapsing airway with behavioral counseling.
Absolutely not. You refer for a medical sleep study.
The gold standard treatment here is a CPAP machine.
Continuous positive airway pressure.
Right. It basically acts as a pneumatic splint.
It uses a steady stream of air to physically hold the throat open
so the patient can actually achieve continuous unbroken sleep.
So let's review the detective work for a second for you, the listener.
Three different patients sit in your chair, all complaining of crushing daytime fatigue.
The clinical history gives you the diagnosis.
Right. If the exhaustion is paired with muscle collapse when they laugh,
you spot the cataphlexy, you suspect narcolepsy, you refer to a neurologist.
If the exhaustion is paired with a partner complaining about choking sounds and snoring,
you suspect sleep apnea, you refer for a sleep study.
And if the exhaustion is paired with laying awake for hours staring at the clock,
you recognize insomnia and you begin CBTI.
You're just matching the specific symptom profile to the underlying mechanism.
Perfect. So having covered the inability to go to sleep and the inability to stay awake,
the notes transition into a totally different realm.
The bizarre things the body does while actively asleep.
Yes. The parasomnias.
And understanding parasomnias is all about mapping them onto the timeline of the sleep cycle.
Right. Because the architecture of our night is split into two vastly different states.
Non-REM sleep and REM sleep.
And the parasomnias that occur in each state are fundamentally different.
The way I think about it clinically, it helps to view the first half of the night,
which is non-REM sleep, as the brain's deep physiological maintenance mode.
Heavy cellular repair, but no conscious processing.
Exactly. The monitor is completely turned off.
So this is when the non-REM arousal disorders occur,
specifically sleep terrors and sleepwalking.
Right. Because the brain is in that deep slow wave state.
So if the motor center is spontaneously activate and the person gets up and walks around
or sits up and screams.
The conscious mind is entirely offline.
Which explains the defining clinical feature of the notes highlight, amnesia.
The patient wakes up the next morning completely oblivious to the fact
they were walking around the kitchen.
Or experiencing a screaming terror.
There was no screen rendering any graphics, so no memory was recorded.
Contrast that with the second half of the night when the brain enters
REM or rapid eye movement sleep, the architecture flips.
The monitor turns on.
REM is a high fidelity virtual reality simulation.
The brain is highly active, processing memories and rendering intense visual environments.
And this is the domain of nightmare disorder.
Because the conscious processing centers are active during REM,
when a patient wakes up from a severe nightmare, they retain a vivid memory of it.
They can recall the exact deeply distressing narrative that woke them up.
The source also briefly flags Russell's Leg Syndrome,
which kind of operates slightly outside this specific timeline.
Oh right, because that's primarily an issue of sleep on set, right?
Yeah, it's an overwhelming, uncomfortable physical urge to move the legs when lying down.
It's a sensorimotor issue, heavily linked to dopamine functioning,
that just severely disrupts the transition into sleep.
But let's stay inside that REM virtual reality simulator for a moment,
because this brings us to what I consider the most staggering revelation in the clinical notes.
It's a big one.
If REM sleep is this high-octane simulation where the brain is rendering dreams of running
or fighting, the body obviously requires a safety mechanism.
Which we touched on earlier with narcolepsy.
Yeah.
During normal REM sleep, the brainstem sends a signal down the spinal cord
to initiate temporary muscle atonia.
Complete paralysis of your voluntary muscles.
Right, it locks the physical body down
so you are safely confined to the bed while your mind navigates the simulation.
But in REM sleep behavior disorder, that lock shatters.
The mechanism fails.
The brainstem no longer sends the paralysis signal.
Which means the person physically acts out their dreams.
They will punch the wall, kick their partner, leap out of bed,
or shout aggressively, all while remaining completely immersed in the REM dream state.
Okay, but wait.
If a patient tells me they kick in their sleep or occasionally thrash around,
my first instinct as a counselor might be to tell them to buy a bigger bed
or look into stress reduction.
Right.
Why is this specific physical sleep quirk a glaring red flag
that requires an immediate medical referral?
This is the critical aha moment.
REM sleep behavior disorder is not just a disruptive sleep habit.
It is one of the most reliable early warning indicators
for severe neurodegenerative diseases.
Like specifically the sinuoclinopathies, right?
Yes.
Parkinson's disease and Lewy body disease.
Lewy body disease being the second most common type
of progressive dementia after Alzheimer's.
Correct.
Both Parkinson's and Lewy body dementia are characterized by the abnormal buildup
of a protein called alpha sinuoclin in the brain.
Okay.
But this protein degradation doesn't start in the motor cortex.
It often begins incredibly deep in the lower brainstem.
Which is exactly where the switch that controls REM sleep paralysis is located.
Exactly.
The destruction of that paralysis switch in the brainstem
is often the very first physiological domino to fall.
It is the earliest observable symptom of the neurodegeneration.
Wow.
This REM sleep disorder can present itself years,
sometimes a decade or more,
before the pathology travels high enough into the brain
to cause the classic resting tremors or cognitive decline.
A decade or more?
I mean, just think about the gravity of that
for a mental health professional listening right now.
A patient comes in for marriage counseling
because they are highly stressed.
Yeah.
And the spouse casually mentions,
he keeps kicking me and violently acting at his dreams lately.
If the counselor knows this specific sleep architecture,
they recognize the broken brainstem lock.
They might be the very first medical professional
to spot the seeds of Parkinson's disease
10 years before the patient's hands ever start to shake.
It perfectly validates the mission of the pass-ready prep notes.
The counselor is operating as a frontline observer.
Yeah.
Identifying that one specific parasomnia
fundamentally alters the patient's long-term medical trajectory.
You don't just treat the stress spreader.
You urgently refer them to a neurologist for neuroprotective screening.
Sleep is not the absence of being awake.
It is a highly vulnerable state
where the deepest functions of our neuroanatomy are laid bare.
It really is.
The way it breaks gives us a direct window
into the structural health of the brain.
Which neatly summarizes the overarching framework
for clinical practice that we've been talking about.
Across all these disorders, the counselor's role is tripartite.
Recognize a mechanism, treat the behavior,
and refer the pathology.
Exactly.
You rewrite the behavioral software.
If the criteria for chronic insomnia are met,
you steer clear of the chemical sedatives
that destroy sleep architecture.
Right.
You initiate CBTI to physically rebuild their sleep drive
through restriction and stimulus control.
And you maintain vigilance for the physiological hardware failures.
A sudden loss of muscle tone triggered by laughter
points to the REM intrusion of narcolepsy.
And loud apneic snoring and breathing pauses
point to an oxygen-deprived collapsing airway.
Both require immediate medical management,
not just a therapy session.
And finally, you monitor the timing of the night
to decode the parasomnias.
You separate the memory-wiped deep maintenance terrors of non-REM
from the vivid high-fidelity nightmares of REM.
And crucially, if that REM simulation loses its safety lock
and the patient begins physically fighting their dreams,
you recognize the failing brainstem.
You flag it as a highly predictive warning
sign for Parkinson's or Lewy body disease.
It requires a phenomenal amount of diagnostic precision on this.
It does.
But by understanding the underlying why
and how of these sleep fractures,
a counselor wields incredible power to change a patient's life,
simply by knowing exactly what to listen for
when they describe their nights.
It's incredible.
And it leaves you with something to really mull over.
If the failure of a microscopic protein in our brainstem
can broadcast a warning siren for Parkinson's a decade
before the disease fully arrives,
simply by letting us kick in our sleep,
what other hidden neurological secrets
are our bodies broadcasting every single night?
While we are completely unconscious,
the machinery is still running,
leaving clues in the dark, just waiting for the right observer
to decode them.
It's a fascinating thought.
That is all for today's deep dive.
Until next time, keep analyzing the patterns,
and we'll see you on the next one.